I've been talking for years about the
immoral unethical alliance between Saudi
Arabia and the United States this is up
in Saudi Arabia we're talking about one
of the most extreme Islamic regimes up
there the Wahhabis regime of Saudi
Arabia is up there with Hamas in terms
of on the farthest uh extreme point on
the radical Islam scale but we have
shared interests with Saudi Arabia both
the US and Saudi Arabia have a shared
interest of Middle East stability for
oil related reasons yet another reason
that staying on oil at all is a national
security risk and finally very late in
the game the United States has said that
they're going to not cut altogether but
limit weapons sales to Saudi Arabia why
because of concerns over civilian
casualties linked to air strikes in
Yemen not the fact that you have a
violent religious theocracy which
beheads people in public in Saudi Arabia
not any of the other stuff I've been
reporting on to you for years and years
and years but because there's some
concern over civilian casualties based
on the air strikes that Saudi Arabia is
conducting in Yemen now to be clear I'm
not saying that those aren't concerns
those absolutely are concerns uh but the
idea that now they've gone over the line
is absolutely laughable and again this
is a reduction not a halt to arms sales
precision-guided weapons will no longer
be delivered to Saudi Arabia based on a
statement from the Pentagon the
President Obama's administration said it
was concerned over quote flaws in the
way that airstrikes were being targeted
in Yemen in October more than a hundred
and forty people were killed in a strike
on a funeral in the country of Yemen
this is like the too little too late
story of the century we've got White
House national security spokesman Ned
price warning that US security
cooperation to Saudi Arabia is not a
blank check if it's not a blank check
it's almost a blank check uh and while
some of the scale sales are being scaled
back the u.s. is still going to continue
providing Saudi Arabia with intelligence
focused on border security I say let us
know when
they stop selling weapons to one of the
most vile and violent regimes and the
reality is that we've already sent them
large arms in the last couple of do of
years and we continue to train and
support them in this attack on Yemen
we're basically showing them how to use
this stuff this is a completely token
change that is going to generate some
good press but it doesn't really
fundamentally change what's going on
there and oh by the way other contracts
are expected to go ahead like for
example a three billion dollar deal to
supply military helicopters to Saudi
Arabia okay the air strike arms those
were being misused but I'm sure Rachel
that the military helicopters are going
to be used in a completely sane and
ethical way I I mean I I don't know I've
been talking about this till I'm almost
literally blue in the face and it just
seems to not matter because oil and
other shared interests are what matter
here we need to end this alliance don't
we we do need to end it but I don't
going I don't really see how that's
going to be feasible for going to
continue to refuel coalition aircraft
and as you mentioned intelligence so I
don't feasibly see an end in sight it's
just optics were slightly scaling back
one piece of the big picture of how we
are a lot allied with Saudi Arabia a
reminder I recommended this documentary
I think it was either last week or the
week before it's called Saudi Arabia
uncovered it's available on Netflix it's
available on Amazon and it's available
at david pakman.com slash
recommendations were all of my
recommendations are listed and it really
exposes a lot of the insane humanitarian
crises that are taking place at our
buddies Saudi Arabia